sociale autant qu'une justice raciale
mais également économique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sauf
[Musique]
les israéliens priés de rester chez eux
depuis la mi-journée au premier jour des
fêtes du nouvel an l'état juif décrète
trois semaines de confinement
généralisée
avec son lot de restrictions conséquence
des centaines de manifestants dans les
rues
l'om s inquiète du niveau de
transmission en europe particulièrement
en espagne et en france des décès qui
augmente pour la première fois depuis le
dégonflement
deuxième semaine du procès en
extradition de julian assange en
grande-bretagne son avocate révèle
l'existence d'une possible main tendue
de washington
rejeté par le fondateur de wikileaks la
grâce en échange de la révélation de la
source du piratage des courriels du
parti démocrate lors de la
présidentielle de 2016
nous verrons dans le détail comment se
sont déroulées ces deux premières
semaines d'audience
julian assange incarcéré dans une prison
de haute sécurité
il risque jusqu'à 175 ans de prison aux
états unis
[Musique]
l'apparition contesté par
vidéoconférence de l'opposante
biélorusses lors d'un débat en urgence à
l'onu à l'initiative de l'allemagne
les diplomates russes chinois et
vénézuélien conteste la procédure ce
conseil doit présenter un état des lieux
d'ici à la fin de l'année la rapporteure
spéciale dit craindre l'installation
d'un nouveau rideau de fer en europe
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce vendredi premier pays
développé par confiner la totalité de sa
population israël qui a demandé à ses
concitoyens de ne plus sortir sauf pour
des raisons essentielles avec des
restrictions de déplacement
de quoi provoquer la colère de certains
le jour où s'ouvrent les fêtes du nouvel
an juif david khalifa colère et
incompréhension pour ces centaines de
manifestants venus protester contre leur
confinement général visant à faire face
à la résurgence de la pandémie la
population israélienne estime le
gouvernement incapable de gérer
l'épidémie est un coupable semble tout
désigné
le premier ministre benyamin nétanyahou
aujourd'hui il y ait eu un rassemblement
c'est la dernière chance d'arrêter un
confinement injustifiée qui ne fait que
nuire à la population
il y a des médecins et des gens qui se
trouvent en première ligne dans la lutte
contre le coronavirus qui vont parler et
présenter des faits montrant qu'il n'y a
pas de logique et pas de justification
pour revenir à un confinement
au contraire le confinement est néfaste
à la population c'est complètement
inacceptable
en mars nous étions nombreux à ne pas
savoir ce qui se passait et nous avons
écouté le gouvernement
désormais il est juste évident qu'il
n'ya aucune logique derrière le
confinement a pas rendre les gens
déprimés bloquées dans leurs maisons
faire des choses mauvaises pour leur
santé c'est ce que le gouvernement nous
dit faire depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire la plus grande de l'histoire
et nous en avons véritablement assez de
tout ça un ras-le-bol qui s'explique par
les mesures drastiques prises par le
gouvernement pour les trois prochaines
semaines à compter de ce vendredi 14
heures heure locale
les israéliens auront interdiction de se
rendre à plus de 500 mètres de chez eux
hormis pour aller faire leurs courses à
la pharmacie ou au travail s'il s'agit
d'une profession jugée essentielle
le tout dans une période particulière en
effet les synagogues sont en général
remplis lors des deux jours de roches et
shana et surtout de yom kippour
mais cette année les fidèles iront prier
dans les synagogues en fonction de la
taille de l'édifice et pour la première
fois de son histoire la grande synagogue
de jérusalem d'accueil rats
pas les célébrations du nouvel an juif
en raison des restrictions dues à
l'épidémie
ces deux derniers jours nous avons
assisté à une autre augmentation
alarmante de la mortalité et à
l'augmentation continue du nombre de
patients gravement malades
c'est pourquoi j'ai eu une longue
conversation aujourd'hui avec le
ministre de la santé
yuli edelstein avec le chef de projet le
professeur rosny gamme so et d'autres
experts maintenant j'estime qu'à la
lumière de cette conversation
dans cette situation de mortalité et
comme de nombreux experts le recommandé
comme nous n'avons peut-être pas d'autre
choix que de resserrer les longs
directrice des lignes directrices que le
chef du gouvernement n'hésitera pas à
durcir si nécessaire des mesures de
confinement perçue comme un coup de
massue par une partie de la population
pays de 9 millions d'habitants
israël a officiellement enregistré plus
de 172 milles 4 2 coronavirus pour mille
cent soixante trois décès plus
inquiétant l'état hébreu le pays qui a
recensé le plus fort taux de
contamination ces deux dernières
semaines
et voyez à présent l'analyse de la
situation en israël avec i'm messika
analyste politique à jérusalem le
premier ministre netanyahou essaye de
prendre des décisions de manière
collégiale il ne fait pas tout seul il
emploie un certain nombre d un certain
nombre de personnes autour de lui il ya
des scientifiques qui sont là ça mais on
est dans un pays déjà il ya deux jours
il ya trois opinions alors imaginez dans
un problème comme celui là où on a du
mal à savoir effectivement ce qu'il faut
faire c'est pas du tout évident que les
gens qui crient dans la rue que j'ai pu
dans l'autopartage juste avant qu'ils
oublient ils font rien pour nous aider
de ça c'est pas aussi évident que ça y'a
pas et c'est pas une solution en plus
sera égale 2 c'est quelque chose qui
tient en compte le paramètre par exemple
on voit qu'en suède
les choses ne sont pas du tout passé
comme nationales prévues en israël
et comme le scénario qui se passe en
france est quasiment dans chaque pays il
ya une problématique tout à fait
différente donc accusé le premier c'est
un peu ce que je trouve que c'est un peu
léger non effectivement comme vous dites
ça parce que justement il ya tellement
de
l'hypothèse qui sont émises par les
scientifiques eux mêmes qui disent une
chose et leur contraire que c'est
complètement c'est pas du tout évident
de prendre au guichet en france après la
grande confusion autour des tests pcr la
haute autorité de santé vient de donner
son feu vert pour réaliser des tests
salivaires mais ces tests sont
inefficaces sur les personnes qui ne
présentent pas de symptômes vous voyez
les derniers chiffres s'afficher à
l'écran la france qui enregistre un
nouveau record de contamination ces
dernières 24 heures treize mille deux
cent quinze nouveaux cas de
contamination et 154 morts hier le
ministre de la santé a annoncé la mise
en place de nouvelles restrictions dans
certaines villes où le virus circule
activement à l'instar de nice ou
bordeaux
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
frédéric adnet directeur des urgences de
l'hôpital avicenne à péage fait à
bobigny
bonsoir frédéric années merci d'être
avec nous sur arte france on va parler
de l'hôpital je voudrais votre réaction
d'abord sur ces tests salivaires qui
donc ont reçu le feu vert de la haute
autorité
reste aussi à avoir l'aval de
l'assurance maladie mais a priori sont
inefficaces sur ceux qui ne présentent
pas de symptômes alors à quoi ça
servirait oui alors il faut savoir que
ces tests salivaires c'est une
simplification du prélèvement à salir sa
mère un prélèvement qui va être moins
douloureux plus facile à la limite qu'on
pourrait faire à nous mêmes mais la
technicité lui du prélèvement reste la
même série que les délais
malheureusement pour rester les mêmes
alors ce prélèvement salivaire il est
homologué et homologué aux états unis à
cinq tests cellulaires au môle 2 jean
vient d'être homologué en france et il
va être réservé dans un premier temps
aux patients symptomatiques puisque
l'étude française que je n'ai pas lu a
révélé que il était moins performant
chez les patients qui sont
asymptomatiques qui sont donc au tout
début de leur infection
alors qu'ils seront ces personnes
symptomatique ce sera juste du
déclaratif ou devront ils voir un
médecin
serait-il judicieux qu'ils aillent voir
un médecin au préalable ça je ne sais
pas du tout si ces tests salivaires et
moi je pense que ça serait logique mais
je ne sais pas du tout si ces tests
salivaires pourront être faits que sur
prescription médicale
moi ça me semble tout à fait logique je
pense qu'il faut remettre le médecin
traitant au centre de décision pour les
tests du coc vie de 19
ça serait logique mais je n'ai pas cette
information parce que le seul habilité à
savoir si effectivement les des patients
au laus un drôle des syndromes
compatible avec la manette ducobu 19 ce
sont évidemment les médecins de famille
les médecins traitants un mois sur le
nombre de morts qui augmenteront voit un
peu plus de 250 nouveaux décès ces
dernières 24 heures qu'en est-il en
seine saint denis à l'hôpital
l'hôpital accueille de plus en plus de
de deux malades
oui dans mon hôpital et dans les
hôpitaux de la seine saint denis on a
toujours cette montée qui est lente et
progressive mais qui petit à petit
remplit complètement l'hôpital et donc
les lits de covile sont de plus en plus
difficiles à trouver
on a un taux d'hospitalisation qui
naquit n'a rien à voir avec la première
vague donc on est entre deux trois
patients par jour mais ça dure longtemps
la première vague elle a duré trois
semaines et là on est quand même à
pratiquement plus d'un mois où cette
montée est lente mais continue et donc
notre hôpital se remplit progressivement
notre service d'animation se remplit
progressivement pour arriver bientôt à
un niveau de saturation donc c'est un
peu ce qui nous inquiète c'est une
cinétique qui n'a rien avant que la
première vague qui est lente mais qui
remplit quand même notre hôpital
effectivement on commence à avoir des
problèmes pour placer nos patients qui
développent cette maladie surtout la
scène ça mais on sait où les nids sont
en tension
c'était le cas notamment pendant le
confinement est ce que vous pensez qu'il
y a une réponse en tout cas une
anticipation de la part du gouvernement
sur les hôpitaux justement puisque le
nombre de morts est en augmentation les
admissions également on voit qu'il faut
il focalise beaucoup sur les tests ne
faudrait-il pas ils focalisaient plutôt
sur les accueille dans les hôpitaux
ah bah écoutez on travaille beaucoup
dessus l essence publique hôpitaux de
paris on a des réunions de prise de
trois fois par semaine on a des plans de
montée en tension et on va commencer à
faire ce qu'on avait fait pour la
première vague c'est à dire à mutualiser
tous les lits de réanimation de villes
de france 2 ap hp non ap hp clinique et
tous les établissements de santé pour
avoir une régulation commune pour
pouvoir placer nos patients dans les
services de réanimation dont tous ces
lits qui vont être disponibles mais
aussi au niveau de l'hospitalisation
conventionnelle c'est à dire hors
régulation pour mutualiser ces lits et
trouver plus facilement un des parcours
de patients adapté à cette maladie
donc 2 de la crise
2 mars l'hôpital a appris justement à
mieux gérer aujourd'hui
bien sûr on a appris beaucoup de choses
d'avoir on connaît mieux le virus on le
prendre je comprends mieux en charge les
patients ils restent moins longtemps
animations la mortalité semble baisser
au niveau de la réanimation toutes
choses étant égales par ailleurs et les
solutions qui ont marché lors de la
première crise et qui ont été pris un
peu en catastrophe
on va reprendre tout ce qui a marché
comme cette cellule de régulation des
lits de réanimation et on va l'art est
appliquée dans cette nouvelle rebond
d'épidémie qui encore une fois n'a rien
à voir la première vague
c'est un rebond avec une mort une
cinétique lente qui nous laisse quand
même un peu de temps pour s'organiser
oui c'est un rebond et non pas une
deuxième vague c'est ce que c'est ce que
vous dites balisé je vous en prie le
terme de vagrant pour envoie toujours à
la vague comme nous avons subi en mars
en mars/avril inquiéter avec des
tsunamis là c'est pas un tsunami si vous
voulez c'est une baignoire qui se
remplit progressivement à ions de donner
une image c'est une baignoire qui se
remplit progressivement et on fait tout
vous pas qu'elle déborde
ce qu'on a vécu à la première vague
c'est une espèce de tsunami qui a tout
balayé devant lui dire question très
importante les personnes âgées qui
seraient infectés seront accueillis à
l'hôpital cette fois écouté la
problématique c'est pas qu'on a qu'on a
délaissé les personnes âgées
il y avait des personnes âgées qui
avaient si vous voulez un état qui
n'étaient pas compatibles avec des soins
lourds de réanimation donc on proposait
pas assez patient une réanimation comme
nous le propose pas pour d'autres
pathologies c'est à dire qu'il ya des
états physiologiques qui font que ces
personnes ne peuvent pas supporter des
réanimations ce sont des patients
grabataire très âgé et c'est donc la
politique reste la même si vous voulez
aller les patients qui n'ont pas de
l'indication de
immersion de soins lourds et kiki qui
ressemble plus à une obstination
déraisonnable et c'est prévu par la loi
bien sûr que c'est pas si on leur
propose pas ces soins lourds par contre
tous les autres patients qui sont si
vous voulez éligibles à des soins de
réanimation vont venir à l'hôpital et
sont soignés
merci beaucoup frédéric adnet d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france et
avec plus de 30 millions de cas dans le
monde l'om est-ce s'inquiète des délais
raccourcis de mise en quarantaine décidé
dans certains pays à l'instar de la
france l'om sms qui juge la situation
alarmante en europe pour le nombre de
nouveaux cas et supérieurs à ceux
enregistrés en mars dernier c'est le cas
notamment au royaume uni où de nouvelles
mesures draconiennes ont été annoncées
dans le nord du pays deux millions de
personnes sont obligées de limiter leurs
contacts sociaux les lieux de
divertissement ont pour obligation de
fermer à 22h des mesures fortes
également présent en espagne avec un
nombre de malades qui a explosé dans les
quartiers les plus modestes de madrid
notamment à un recond finement est
d'ailleurs à l'étude pour ces quartiers
les plus défavorisés
le procès de julian assange à londres
fin de la deuxième semaine d'audiences
pour le fondateur de wikileaks la
justice britannique doit décider ou pas
de l'extrader vers les états unis le
lanceur d'alert australien qui risque
jusqu'à 175 ans de prison s'il est
reconnu coupable sur le sol américain
il est poursuivi notamment pour avoir
publié des documents secrets de
l'administration américaine
et cela en collaboration d'ailleurs à
l'époque avec plusieurs médias
internationaux comme le journal le monde
ses avocats dénoncent un procès
politique pour avoir fait un travail de
journaliste on fait le point sur ces
deux semaines d'audience avec notre
journaliste elle meriem larbi la
deuxième semaine du procès de julian
assange vient de s'achever les deux
semaines qui viennent de s'écouler ont
été marqués par la difficulté pour les
observateurs journalistes publics
organisations non gouvernementales
d'accéder aux audiences avec des
problèmes techniques récurrents des
problèmes d'accès à la salle d'audience
à cause de l'épidémie du coronavirus les
deux semaines ont été également marquée
par des témoignages qui on peut le dire
ont marqué les esprits il faut savoir
que l'accusation américaine contre
julian assange portent principalement
sur l'allégation selon laquelle
wikileaks aurait mis des vies en danger
lors des révélations de 2010 sur la
guerre d'irak et d'afghanistan
il s'agirait de vie des irakiens et des
afghans qui travaillaient pour le compte
du gouvernement américain et dont le nom
aurait été révélé par wikileaks
or des témoignages sont venus remettre
en cause ce ces allégations et ses
accusations notamment celui de jungle un
journaliste allemand qui avait travaillé
pour des rssi der spiegel un des cinq
journaux qui avaient participé aux
fuites de wikileaks qui avait participé
à la publication de défi de wikileaks et
qui a assuré au tribunal que julian
assange était très préoccupé par cette
question et qu'il avait demandé à tous
les journaux de faire très attention à
expurger les noms des personnes qui
pouvaient être vulnérable il a rappelé
également que le département d'état
américain avait été consulté avant toute
publication de wikileaks et que suite
aux préconisations du département d'état
julian assange avait décidé de ne pas
publier plus de quinze mille documents
confidentiels le tribunal a également
entendu daniel
albert qui est l'homme des pentagon
papers sur la guerre du vietnam en 1971
il avait fait des révélations qui avait
défrayé la chronique
daniel ellsberg à a dit à la juge fin
des sabbats réserve qu'il estimait que
les publications de wikileaks était
d'intérêt public et il il a prévenu que
selon lui du lien assange ne pourrait
pas bénéficier d'un procès équitable
s'il venait à être extradé aux états
unis
la biélorussie au coeur d'un débat aux
nations unies aujourd'hui une réunion au
lendemain d'une déclaration du président
loukachenko il a évoqué je cite une
possible guerre avec ses voisins accusé
de soutenir la contestation contre son
gouvernement dans le cadre de ce débat à
svetlana et petits canots kayaks
candidate à l'opposition à l'élection
présidentielle s'est exprimé dans un
message vidéo à l'invitation de
diplomate européen
la biélorussie qui est toujours en proie
à des manifestations après l'élection
contestée du président alexandre
loukachenko avec un peu plus de 80% être
des voix voyez ce qu'en dit notre
correspondante à moscou vera goffman le
pose en biélorussie en attique annonce
qu'elle a appelé la communauté
internationale à réagir avec la plus
grande fermeté face à la situation dans
son pays à l'occasion d'un débat ici par
l'union européenne l'ex candidate à la
présidentielle
réfugié en lituanie s'est exprimé dans
un message vidéo devant le conseil des
droits de l'homme des nations-unies
je vous propose d'écouter un extrait de
son intervention la situation en
biélorussie exige une attention
immédiate de la part de la communauté
internationale des manifestants
pacifiques sont illégalement détenus
frappée et violée nous la majorité
démocratique de biélorussie nous avons à
plusieurs reprises exprimé notre
attachement à l'état de droit aux
valeurs démocratiques et au dialogue
pacifique
l'intervention de ce toit le titre
annonce qu'elle n'est pas du goût des
représentants russes et biélorusses qui
ont jugé qu'il était contraire au
règlement du conseil des droits de
l'homme
écoutez à brétigny moigne je voudrais
attirer votre attention et l'attention
de toutes les personnes présentes ici
brad 80 sur le fait que le format des
débats urgents qui se déroule
aujourd'hui ne prévoit pas la
participation des noms représentants du
commissariat des nations unies aux
droits de l'homme cher au commissaire
adjoint des nations unies aux droits de
l'homme ni du rapporteur spécial ni de
personne d'autre
sauf les états risquent aucune
manifestation ne s'est déroulé
conformément à la loi sur l'organisation
de rassemblements de masse en
l'occurrence nous ne parlons pas de
l'interdiction du droit de manifester
pacifiquement mais de la procédure de sa
mise en oeuvre
les participants violer la loi par
conséquent il ya eu des milliers
d'arrestations
en dépit des déclarations des opposants
au gouvernement
les manifestations de la période du 9 au
12 août n'était pas toujours facile
fixer les murs des baraques ce citoyen
titre annonce que est attendu le 21
septembre à bruxelles ont rencontré les
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'ue eux et se rendre ensuite au
parlement européen l'union européenne ne
reconnaît pas alexandre lukashenko comme
président de la biélorussie se prépare à
imposer d'importantes sanctions aux
dirigeants du pays celles ci seront
discutées par les ministres européens
des affaires étrangères puis soumises à
leurs chefs d'état et de gouvernement
lors du sommet européen des 24 et 25
septembre
on en vient aux derniers éléments
concernant la sphère navalni selon ses
proches des traces de nos vies de choc
aurait été retrouvé sur une bouteille
d'eau qui lui appartiendrait une vidéo a
été postée par l'entourage d'alexei
navalni sur les réseaux sociaux
on y voit effectivement la chambre d'un
hôtel à tomsk en russie là où justement
alexeï navalni a séjourné pendant trois
jours la bouteille d'eau aurait été
ramassé 1 par des amis juste après son
malaise survenu le 20 août dernier dans
l'avion qui le ramenait à moscou
interrogé sur cette bouteille le porte
parole du gouvernement allemand se
refuse pour l'instant à tout commentaire
voyez ce qu'en ont dit la russie le
gouvernement allemand a pris note de la
vidéo que l'équipe de monsieur navalni a
posté en ligne
si vous avez des questions concernant
cette vidéo vous devez les poser à
l'équipe de monsieur navalni
nous avons demandé à la russie de
s'expliquer de façon urgente à ce sujet
et cette demande est toujours
d'actualité
à ce propos nous sommes en contact avec
nos partenaires européens et amis comme
nous l'avons annoncé mais nous ne sommes
pas encore arrivés à une conclusion je
n'ai rien à ajouter
concernant les traces de neuvic choc sur
une bouteille trouvait dans une chambre
d'hôtel à tomsk nous ne pouvons pas
l'expliquer parce que s'il y avait une
bouteille cette bouteille aurait dû être
emporté quelques phare en allemagne ou
ailleurs
donc ce qui aurait pu être un élément de
preuve qui indiquerait que cela a été un
empoisonnement auraient été emportés
pourquoi
c'est une autre question nous n'avons
pas la possibilité d'analyser cette
bouteille par conséquent nos
professionnels n'ont rien à dire à ce
sujet qik cette histoire est trop
absurde pour qu'on puisse croire qui que
ce soit sur parole nous n'allons donc
croire personne sur parole y avait-il
une bouteille ou pas des toxicologues
disque s'il ya une bouteille qui portent
des traces de sept agents neurotoxiques
militaire il est très peu probable que
cette bouteille plus d'être emporté par
quelqu'un la personne n'aurait pas le
temps de le faire
donc voilà le niveau d'absurdité ainsi
que cette liste de questions qui se
posent augmente de jour en jour le seul
moyen de faire la lumière de manière
convaincante sur ce qui s'est passé est
d'échanger des informations des
biomatériaux les éléments de preuve et
si nécessaire d'organiser à un travail
en commun entre nos médecins afin
d'analyser la situation
la chine ciblés par les états unis dans
le dossier de taiwan my pompéo le
secrétaire d'état des états unis
critiquent je cite les fanfaronnades
militaire de la chine contre l'archipel
il serait sur le point d'acheter des
armes aux états unis ce qui irrite
particulièrement pékin thomas gonnet les
états unis ventes d armes à taiwan
ce n'est pas un scoop ce qui est plus
surprenant en revanche c'est le rythme
adopté par washington pour ses marchés
avec taipei jusqu'à présent les
exportations étaient espacées dans le
temps pour ne pas trop froisser pékin
mais cette fois ci ce sont sept systèmes
d'armes qui devraient être achetés
simultanément par taïwan selon des
sources proches des discussions est cité
par plusieurs agences de presse les
marchés concernent des missiles de
croisière des drones ou encore des mines
en clair des armes destinées à ce que
taiwan se défendent d'une supposée
incursions et demi sur son territoire et
quand on parle des demies on comprend
clairement qu'il s'agit de la chine
l'empiré du milieu considère taïwan
comme un territoire chinois
il faut dire aussi que les liens
économiques sont très forts entre taipei
et pékin que les états unis vendent des
armes à taiwan dans un contexte de
relations au plus bas avec la chine
c'est clairement vécu comme une nouvelle
provocation par les autorités chinoises
surtout que cette vente s'accompagne
d'une visite inédite
comme annoncé par un communiqué cette
semaine le sous secrétaire d'état
américain en charge de l'énergie de la
croissance économique et de
l'environnement et en élite à taïwan un
déplacement très rare pour un officiel
de ce rang et qui déplaît fortement à
pékin les etats-unis ont délibérément
organisé la visite du sous-secrétaire
d'état à taïwan ce qui constitue une
grave violation du principe d'une seule
chine et va à l'encontre des trois
communiqués conjoints etats unis chine
cela encourage l'attitude arrogante des
forces séparatistes indépendantistes de
taiwan et nuit aux relations etats unis
chine ainsi qu'à la paix et à la
stabilité du
de taïwan la chine s'y oppose fermement
il ya déjà fait de sérieuses
observations aux états unis en août déjà
le ministre américain de la santé
s'était rendu sur place provoquant là
encore la colère de la diplomatie
chinoise
on notera également que cette semaine à
new york la représentante américaine aux
nations unies a dîné avec un responsable
taïwanais ne cachant pas ses intentions
à savoir se dresser face à pékin et
promouvoir l'émancipation de taïwan
tout cela se déroule dans un contexte
très particulier pékin et washington
s'opposent sur de nombreux dossiers
accusations d'espionnage guerre
commerciale ou encore gestion de la
pandémie
et si les états unis intensifient leurs
pressions sur la chine
c'est aussi parce que trump en a fait un
argument de campagne
pour preuve cette publicité réalisée par
l'équipe de donald trump est dévoilée
par le site dit il
intitulé sibide on gagne la chine gagne
une vidéo qui met en parallèle des
propos de joe biden plutôt conciliant
avec pékin et la courbe des emplois
perdus sur le sol américain
[Musique]
ce clip de campagne illustre à merveille
à quel point la thématique des relations
sino américaines s'est invitée dans
l'élection présidentielle trump accuse
byden de faiblesse face à la chine
et ce dernier rétorque en pointant du
doigt l'échec de l'accord commercial
signé par trump avec pékin à moins de 50
jours du scrutin la campagne américaine
se joue donc aussi à plusieurs milliers
de kilomètres de washington
et c'est dans ce contexte que les
applications tic toc
et oui chat seront bientôt interdits
toit aux états unis contexte de grande
tension avec la chine on l'a vu le
téléchargement de kde ces deux
applications ne sera plus disponible à
partir de dimanche washington accusent
les applications d'espionnage pour le
compte de pékin 1 tick tock démentent
ces allégations et dénoncent cette
décision américaine voyez ce qu'en dit
thierry valette il est avocat et
spécialiste du numérique
ce que prévoit le décret donc à partir
de dimanche
c'est que les applications qui ont déjà
été téléchargées reste bien évidemment
sur les smartphones les ordinateurs des
des consommateurs américains mais en
revanche il ne sera plus possible en
théorie de télécharger de nouvelles
versions de cette de cette application
tik tok et oui chat est notamment de ne
plus ensuite utiliser les mises à jour
qui pourrait être faite ce qui rendrait
obsolète les anciennes versions déjà
déjà existante et il serait donc
interdit aux plateformes donc à apple et
android de utiliser les applications
dans leurs stores dans l'eure dans leur
boutique en ligne
donc techniquement c'est possible alors
en revanche ce qui est prévu c'est que
tik tok va avoir un espèce de délai
jusqu'au 12 novembre vous l'avez vous
l'avez indiqué pour trouver
éventuellement une solution avec avec
oracle pour que ce cette application
soit rachetée aux états unis alors bien
évidemment je précise que tout ça ne
concerne que les états unis les shows
qui ont requis toc en france ne sont
absolument pas impactés par par cette
décision unilatérale des états unis et
c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
dans les bancs où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs
certes chohada et tout le monde discute
est finalement dumont discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois des images assez touchants
de l'armée qui était presque impliqué
avec les manifestants aujourd'hui on
sent que le ton a changé c'est la cause
d un politique et sont en train de
manipuler l'armée on sait très bien
pourquoi ils nous tirent dessus c